[Music]
so i can't
push on him pushing on me he's got a
yawn
and i have a hit he keeps going that way
and i pulled him that's a young young
he's also clothing dependent what if
he's not wearing a big ghee
well i'm [\h__\h] out of luck now his
energy already starts on a curve do you
see the the
x y has changed so he comes in
oh and his energy is going that way
well that means there's centrifugal
energy to my rotation
and that's what i use so his energy's
going
that way and i keep leading it and it
gets
stuck because i'm making it with some
triple
energy generating his centrifugal energy
there becomes a friction and adhesion
right here
boom and i do the same thing again he's
getting up
he's going that way and i am here again
with this centripetal energy you see
that i don't need to grab them
it's energetic right here energetic
energetic
boom energetic
this is different
energetic energetic
no closing dependency
no grip dependency
there's some energy going there then
it's done okay
so he's passed i'm in using it
same thing you guys are here you move
and then you come in
the techniques on the on the hand the
techniques
[Music]
not here boom
oh so everything's kind of put the gash
on the head right there
[Music]
okay but at this part
this hand that had this centrifugal
energy creating the adhesion
it started to go off
so it as every individual move has
whether it is yin or yang has its own
individual
face so while it's again here
it's in its yang face but now it's
starting to go off
that's where the other hand comes
but if i do this that's a clash
take it off you'll feel this go into its
yin face
and boom where that one will enter its
appropriate yam face
here oh
generally all things being equal let's
say it's not before
12 o'clock it's going to be after 12.
it's right around there
should be free moving should not have
weight
slowing it down slowing it down
this is where the control is the control
is on the head
so you don't use the other hand to uh to
cut
and turn him you're on the inside you're
not covered
you need to be on the outside the
outside
boom okay onward
here it's this is too late
this arm does mean something whoa
right here whoa okay
straight hands come up palm
up and push right here in the mandible
it'll fit in your paw in your heel palm
where your sword goes your pistol grip
right in there
boom
boom here not here here boom
friction is here
[Music]
here no here here's the control
whoa throwing
here comes the entry low down right in
the mandible
up
this cross opens
leg comes in fine
go back i'm here this cross opens
and the leg comes in right into that
trap boom
underneath then find it
okay okay listen
this is a look all locks are traps
i do not put them on he kind of falls
into it
all right and for trapping open-end
triangles
is what i always want so i'm doing the
technique
kick there we go boom
here opening triangle
and then the bottom leg comes up
so i'm here like this put that leg down
i'm here like this that lid comes in
right away
not get the arm that elbow will not be
there
here in and it's on
then find it
so same thing my body keeps moving
[Music]
then open
okay